[Music]
not to you
seal we got another game with black
let's begin with e4 e5
obviously the movie five okay so queen
h5 this is a very very common move
at the beginner level and i forgot to do
a five minute game i'll make sure to do
it next
queen h5 attacks upon e5 you guys all
probably know that it's a bad idea oh my
goodness a thousand bits from anonymous
your bishop c4
threatens checkmate how do we defend
ladies and gentlemen against the
scholars mate
how do we defend against it do not play
knight f6 that doesn't defend against it
do not move the queen out we play g6 i
will later explain
why not queen e7 okay he brings his
queen back to f3
and he threatens checkmate again so
we're just going to develop the knight
and
intercept his queen's control of f7 now
he cannot take my knight
because the knight is defended but now i
find this queen to be very annoying guys
i find this queen to be very known can
we chase this queen away
can we chase this queen away i don't
want to deal
with i don't want to deal with the
possibility of scholars me and guess
what i'm centralizing my knife but
daniel aren't you moving the same piece
more than once in the opening didn't you
say that you shouldn't make
you know more than one move in the
opening now yes but remember every rule
that i share has a lot of exceptions
and he has played his queen already two
times
so i can afford in turn to delay my
development by a move and get rid of
this pesky queen
in an actual classical game i would have
played bishop g7
but i just want to illustrate okay he's
played queen e3
whenever there's a knight on d4 royal
family fork
boom do we take the rook no we do not we
look for a better move we take the queen
we take the queen
we're gonna be up a queen and not only
are we going to be up a queen
his king is going to have to move away
from castling
and that's just going to be a total
complete disaster okay
so basically this game is already over
but i'm going to talk a little bit about
how to convert advantages
assuming he doesn't resign assuming he
doesn't resign
how to convert advantages trade versus
okay
advantages so we take the queen now
here's the important thing guys when you
are up a queen
and particularly when your opponent's
king is out in the open like this what
do you need to do
you have to open up the center because
only by opening up the center
essentially are you going to make
manifest
your uh huge lead in material so how do
we open the center
how do we open the center yeah d5 that's
it we open the center by playing t5 two
defenders
two attackers we can safely proceed with
knight takes d5
okay he goes knight f3 now he attacks
our pawn can we
develop a piece and simultaneously
defend the pawn
can we defend it can we develop a piece
and simultaneously defend the pawn
yeah we can what is this called this is
called fiance
this is called fiance i'm going to put
this in the chat
fiance is an italian word that literally
means to develop a bishop
to the long diagonal he's got knight t3
okay so let's just take the knight and
uh
another very important piece of advice
when you're up material
you still want to develop charlie um
actually had this weakness for a very
long time
he would win a queen and then he would
forget to develop and he'd still get
checkmated he's gone d4 so
he does our bidding for us whenever
there is a capture
and i will talk more about this after
the game you have to take stock of what
has changed
have there been any files that have
opened up
as a result of this trade guys and can
we occupy those files with anything
yes sure we can we can go rookie
x-raying the king
notice how not only am i up a queen but
i'm opening up the center and i'm
developing my pieces now to very active
squares
now we're just going to take the knight
and this is an instructive moment do you
guys see the pin
do you see that because of the pin this
bishop is immobile it cannot move
so is there any pieces or pawns that we
can take because the bishop is
essentially
a ghost yes sir troop commander good job
sandeep we can take this one now a lot
of people look at this
we're blundering a bishop no we're not i
i told you to count attackers and
defenders
this is not a defender okay it's
immobile so only the rook is defending
the pawn but the queen is another
attacker so if the rook takes we would
have taken the queen now
can we take on e3 no we cannot so i have
a question for you guys can we move
a queen away in order to keep the bishop
protected
but to unpin our own bishop where can we
move the queen and there's two squares
yup we have six
we move the queen away simultaneously
defend the bishop and now we are ready
to take his bishop with ours keep
trading pieces and then we're going to
attack that pawn with our queen
that's how we're going to checkmate him
okay so he's taken
we can obviously take he cannot take our
queen because of the pin now we're up a
queen and a rook
he's gone rookie one very important in
such positions
involve all of your pieces i'm asking
myself are there any pieces that are not
doing anything
there's a rook let's bring that rook
into the game we don't have to move our
queen away now very important if he
moves his king away
we all when we have a piece that is
untouchable due to a pin
and he moves his king away from that pin
that's a situation in which we have to
be very careful i'm just going to
sacrifice my rook for the bishop
because i'm up so and i'm going to talk
about that after the game
um and i'm going to do five minutes from
now on okay because
i'm sensitive to the fact that i you
know this is a little bit too frantic
queen takes f3 now i'm just vacuuming up
all of the spawns and
this is a great time to uh
the the advice i shared for you um which
is that when you're up this much
material
you don't need to hunt this pawn you can
just go straight for the checkmate and
as you guys are pointing out we just
bring the rook and remember
if the pawn were on g7 we would not do
that because rookie 8 would be checkmate
okay he's gone rookie two i'm going to
give him a check on d1 and i'm going to
checkmate him on h1
we could have also taken the rook and
the bishop and then just promoted the c
pawn but this is a little bit faster
earlier you had queen b2 check to sack
the exchange to win the rock on b1
yeah so when you're completely winning
like this and he resigns
when you're completely winning like this
there's multiple ways to accomplish
things
i'm trying to choose the method that is
most most
instructive okay so take everything with
a grain of salt
okay so one moment guys please
so um bishop c4 was played by white now
a lot of people in this position and
hikaru famously has played queen h5
even in classical games um it's not such
a bad move but
obviously it's not good i will do five
minute guys
okay so charlie also had
another weakness which is that when he
would make moves he would forget that
these moves
would block the development of other
pieces so queen e7 is inaccurate what is
a block it blocks the development of the
bishop
blocks the development of the bishop now
let's say that we did play queen e7
but we still wanted to develop this
bishop can somebody tell me how
we could still develop the bishop and
could somebody tell me the word i have
introduced
which describes this particular
development beautiful you guys are sharp
fianchetto g6 that also simultaneously
attacks the queen
then we would fianchetto the bishop but
another reason i don't like this move
is that after knight c3 white could do
something very similar
to what we did which is attack our queen
and centralize the knight
why are we allowing this there's no need
to allow it we go g6
queen f3 knight f6 obviously cannot take
the knight
because the queen is defending that
particular square
okay so he goes d3 knight t4 um
so kodak says why don't we play queen f6
because
doesn't that not block the development
of the bishop well yeah
first of all it makes the queen
voluntarily second of all
it blocks the natural development of the
knight to f6 yeah exactly
okay so he goes d3 knight t4 where
should he have gone with the queen the
only move would have been queen d1
and after queen d when i would have
fianced my bishop
and how would you proceed if you were
white how can you chase this knight away
from d4
is there a way to chase this knight from
d4 and this is an important move to
figure out c3 is correct you could also
play knight f3
but after knight takes f3 again the
queen would have come out
and now the queen has made three moves
that's a little bit
on the extreme side so i would go c3
here and then just continue developing
black has great development i'm fine but
why so is white
okay so he went queen e3 knight takes c2
knight takes e3 and now i play d5 so i
hope it makes sense to everybody that
when you're up let's say a queen or a
rook
you want to open up the center because
only in that way is the full power of
the queen going to be displayed now is
it a bad idea here to develop your
pieces
absolutely not it's totally fine also to
complete your development
you could also prepare the move d5 how
could we prepare the move d5
with a pawn okay and that would also be
a very sensible concept right to play d5
so that we can recapture
on d5 of the pawn and keep our center
controlled by pawn but we don't need to
do that that's not necessary
okay knight f3 fianchettoing and
simultaneously developing
knight c3 now i want to talk about the
concept of training
and i'm going to introduce the general
advice here and then i'm going to kind
of
keep talking about it through the lens
of the following games
this is an age-old problem which a lot
of people are very confused by
do you trade when you are up material do
you trade
and if so how much do you trade when do
you trade now here's what i'm going to
say and nobody's going to like this
answer
it depends you cannot say with any
degree of certainty
whether you trade when you're up
material i would say it's 50 50.
there are cases when you want to trade
there are cases when you don't want to
trade there are cases
when you can trade or not trade and it's
equally as good
so let me explain i'm going to give you
guys a sample position
and in the sample position i'm going to
explain
um i'm going to explain the rationale
behind both of those options and i'm
going to show you guys
why both can be possible and why it can
be hard to decide
okay i'll help you guys understand in
which cases you trade
in which cases you don't trade so let me
set up for you guys
a sample position a very simple simple
position just give me a second please
[ __ ] with a thousand bits
thank you so much appreciate it nicola
okay so let me give you guys a good
example here
okay go and
trust me this example is going to be
really really simple
okay really simple um
it's just that i'm trying to illustrate
the concept so i know people might roll
their eyes at this okay
whoa codex with five gifted holy stop it
guys crazy support today
i really appreciate it coda i'm so happy
and lenser with 500 bits of course this
is going on youtube
i'm so happy people are enjoying this
this is just the beginning
um and of course i'm running out of gas
here so um i'll have more energy and
subsequent speed runs but i'm trying my
best here and i appreciate that people
are so kind
generous as always okay please give me a
moment guys
please give me one moment here okay
so this i'm so so happy that this format
is is working now let me paste the
position in
to show you guys what i mean by it
depends
okay so set up position and then we're
going to return to the game very briefly
and continue
at the end and here we go okay flip the
board and it's white's plan so we have
this position in front of us white is
going forward
and we have a decision to make what is
this decision
and i'm not talking mcdonald's or burger
king what's the decision
what's the decision i mean
trade or not to trade to be or not to be
to trade queens or not to trade queens
now there are two ways of winning
hypothetically speaking a position in
which you're off a lot of material and
by the way just to operationalize this
thank you for those bits when i say up
material
for the purpose of talking beginner
chess i usually mean
let's say a piece up or more so like a
bishop or night or more when we're
talking like up a pawn
none of this applies like a pawn
advantage is too small
to really make a lesson out of it right
now
i will talk about being a pawn op but
maybe when we're playing slightly more
advanced players
we can take the queen or we cannot take
it
now one of the ways of winning a game of
reference here and that's what everybody
learns it's the trade pieces and then
win the resulting position because your
opponent
has nothing but a king left how are you
going to win this
what's going to be white's plan the
easiest plan of winning this position
get rid of the ladies uh cut him off
don't let the king this is called
cutting him off and
boom boom boom boom boom boom we make a
new queen and
um we win if we didn't have the b-pawn
i will talk later about how to win such
positions but
the other way of winning a position
where europe material is to use that
material to mount an attack against the
king
just by definition um so let me give you
guys an analogy
let's say you had a soccer game in a
soccer field there's 11 players right
let's say somebody came up to you with
an option you could remove
10 players from each side 10 players
from each side
and you would be left with one player
leonel messi
and leonesse would literally play the
opposing team which had no players
obviously you would take that option
right lionel messi would just run up to
the empty goal
and he would score um but the second
option would be
to leave let's say all 11 players
against 10 players
and obviously like who would ever do
that but there are situations
in which the 11 players are so good
that leaving them on the board is
actually going to result in a faster win
we can compare that to a situation in
which lionel messi
in order to score that goal has to fly
to the stadium from elsewhere
and that's going to take him a very long
time whereas an attack can win the game
immediately i know that's a weird
analogy
if we were to keep queens on the board
look what you could do check
and if the queen blocks what do we do
actually this move also applies after
king h8
what is white's best move checkmate if
the king moves away
the king moves away we go rook a and
this is a pin against the queen do you
see how quickly
and how much faster white wins the game
here if he keeps the queens on the board
this is a simple example if we have a
lot of pieces on the board sometimes
it's worthwhile not to trade but rather
to go directly for an attack
and when you have more pieces than your
opponent the attack can just crash
through immediately
so that is why i know the analogy goes
far but now you guys won't forget it
hopefully you can see why it depends
okay um because in certain cases an
attack decides the game a lot faster
than trying to trade
the other the other thing to be cautious
of is that when you're trying to trade a
lot of pieces
it can be very easy to ignore it can be
very easy to ignore
um tactical threats you might be so
fixated on trading pieces that you
forget that there exists
various threats like back rank made for
example and i can show you guys
plenty of examples from my games and
others games where this happens
by and large it depends as i play my
early games
i will try to let you guys in on my
decision making process in terms of
whether or not
to trade pieces here i have an extra
queen and this king is wide open
so it literally makes zero sense uh to
trade too many pieces so take rookie
eight
bishop g4 just developing now you might
well daniel you just said don't trade
and now you're trading
this isn't really a big time trade right
i'm getting rid of his knight the knight
defends the pawn
and i'm forcing him to either ruin his
pawn structure
or bring his king closer in uh where it
can be checked by the queen
fatal owl asks if you're bad at
calculating attack should you always
trade them no well here's the thing
when you're a beginner you don't want to
develop any complexes or big weaknesses
right so if you feel like you're bad at
visualizing and attacking
i know that it's painful but force
yourself to sometimes go for the attack
because that is the only way that you
get better at things you struggle with
is by not avoiding them and thrusting
yourself
into whatever field whatever area you
struggle it okay
um and what often happens part of the
reason beginners get stuck
at a level where you feel like why can i
improve
is because you've spent so long avoiding
a particular area of the game let's say
end games or openings
um that by the time you finally get
around to start learning it
your opponents who are rated 16 1700
just have so much more experience than
you at those areas
it's very very hard to eradicate those
long-term weaknesses
in your game so face your fears on the
chess board and off the chess board
okay the rest of the game was very very
simple
um we don't really have to look at it uh
but basically i just won the pawn
using the pin um queen f6
and just last thing guys when this move
is played
most beginners would automatically play
rook b8
and here's the important pin remember
guys that i said don't get
way laid by meaningless material when
you're up a queen
like don't you play five moves just to
win a pawn
well the same thing goes the other way
he's attacking our pawn
big whoop that's just the pawn we're up
a queen
okay so we don't need to spend a bunch
of time making our rook passive to
defend this meaning was fun
we can just go straight for the throat i
see this all the time
players getting obsessed with defending
every single little pawn when they're up
so much material they could easily
afford to give up the fun
and even more just get down to business
are there any questions about this game
or can i move on i'll play one or two
more
and then i'll pause for today are there
any other questions about this game
about what i just talked about
and i want to take everybody's questions
why not queen b2 check on wish move
i don't i don't understand exactly where
oh okay so queen b2 check would not have
won the rook because after king f1
the king unpins itself and now you can't
take the rook because the bishop takes
c1 but what can black do here in order
to win some material
what can black do to to um orchestrate
some material
rook takes c3 this is called removing
the defender
and it comes back to something i said in
the first game when there is only one
piece defending
a particular other piece and no pawns
defending a particular other piece
this is what i call a type 2 undefended
piece i've developed some terminology to
talk about this i will talk about it
later
i'm letting you guys in on some stuff
that i've developed and usually share
only with my students
but i think they'll be totally i think
they'll be okay with this
when a piece is defended by only other
only one other piece
it's basically still undefended because
you can remove its only defender and
then it's essentially undefended
that's what you can do here and at the
end of the day you are
hanging around not currently accepting
any students guys i'm
really really slammed as it is but i'll
talk later uh
about that as well okay so that was the
game and final thing
not getting fixated on material this is
called an exchange by the way rook for a
bishop or a knight is called an exchange
i sacrifice an exchange
and uh i just checkmated him this would
be a great example of trading versus not
trading i can take and trade and win a
piece
and win by just promoting the pawn also
when
by checkmating him on the spot because i
have so many pieces here in the attack
[Music]
you